somewhere deep beneath the waves of the
Atlantic is this spectacular shimmering
pinnacles and rocks which have been
named the lost city there is no other
place known on earth that is anything
like it here despite the absence of
light or oxygen hydrocarbons the very
building blocks of life are being
spontaneously created in a reaction
between these rocks and the seawater
scientists believe life on Earth may
have begun in a place like this billions
of years ago we know from the rock
record that these type of rocks existed
during the early Earth we know in
different parts of Earth's history that
we have these type of rocks but we've
never found it on the seafloor being
able to understand the processes and the
whole system of lost city being able to
understand it now could give us clues as
to what went on in the past and how life
started yet today it is on the threat
Sky News has learned that the lost city
has now been designated as part of a
mining exploration site given over to
Poland the decision was taken by an
institution called the International
seabed Authority a UN agency based in
Jamaica the lost city is an active
hydrothermal vent and it is in the area
that has been allocated to Poland the is
a job is to decide which parts of the
seafloor in international waters can be
mined by which country but some have
asked whether it's paying enough
attention to the environmental
consequences they think the ISA has a
pretty good record of transparency the
meetings of its political bodies all
public meetings held here in Jamaica we
know very little about what happens
inside those meetings and how those
decisions are taken recommendations are
made by a body called the legal and
technical Commission which is a body
that is elected by the countries and is
empowered to review the applications the
moment there are 30 have you ever in the
ISAs history rejected a license
no so far no license application has
been rejected and for environmentalists
there are no easy answers so why do we
need to go down towards the seabed well
it largely comes down to these the
primary ingredient in mobile phone
batteries and batteries in electric cars
is cobalt and 90% of the world's known
resources of cobalt lies in structures
underneath the sea same thing for the
big ingredient when it comes to solar
panels in other words if we want to have
a green future we might have to go and
line the seabed and this British company
is making the machines that will enable
us to do that why do we need to go under
the water so tomorrow we've got a
growing population around the world
coupled with that that population per
capita their mineral requirements
they're increasing as countries develop
if we look at our sources on land
most of the easy better deposits have
been mined for decades deep-sea mining
was a pipe dream now that dream is
looking increasingly like a reality with
major consequences we are only now
starting to calculate Eddie Conway Sky
News